you talking about what was it mini clip
just reminded me of like
all the did you guys i haven't played
like my whole life on mini club like
did you get how many do you guys
remember like the good old-fashioned
flash games that yeah
have to play on your school internet
yeah because actual games wouldn't work
i
remember being like in like in like the
lunch break being like yo i know which
website balloons to our defense is on
type in this code balloon's tower
defense 2 is available on this url i
know
it's all about the helicopter game man
yeah i remember remember that helicopter
game which was like pre-angry birds
before like oh
yeah yeah i remember that one it was the
most difficult gameplay with just the
spacebar
when that when what like somehow one of
those websites with
all of the games got through the filter
it was like opening the floodgates and
you were like
holy [ __ ] yeah because i remember at in
my primary school
mini clip it was immediately oh yeah
mini clip was planned but then someone
was like
i know a website called albino sheep and
it's
not blocked on the firewall don't tell
the teachers
got all the games did you ever have um
someone like because and the school's
right all the pcs are hooked up to like
the main admin
yeah yeah yeah uh one of the kids in my
school like changed the like background
of all the things and it was the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was like because the teacher left the
room for one
moment yeah he changed all the
backgrounds to alien versus predator
but okay the predator was just like a
priest
[Laughter]
and so a bunch of 13 year old kids are
just doing their thing and they minimize
like word document or like
the [ __ ] powerpoint and they just see
like [ __ ] like one of the popes
holding hands with the predator
of the with the alien or something and
it was just the funniest [ __ ] thing
ever i remember being so amused by this
that that is just peak 12 year old i
love it yeah i remember just 12 year old
me thought man
nothing's ever going to live up to this
moment bro that was the funniest [ __ ]
best prank of all time this is just giga
brain bro
i can't imagine it i remember like i t
class back in the day like in school i t
class was just like a second
playground oh dude everyone just [ __ ]
around yeah yeah it was
no nobody actually did the work and i
remember like
if you had to do the work it was like a
five-minute job yeah
because they were teaching you stuff
that you were probably already using
like
they used to teach us like microsoft
word and powerpoint not even like excel
and everyone everyone at age like 10
already knows how to use like
uh powerpoint yeah at least our age they
did i don't know about now it might just
be different but
when i was growing up everyone knows
powerpoint everyone had made a
powerpoint for like every other class
that they had
yeah right but they had to go above and
beyond by being like do you know a thing
called transition
they will they'll really not really
spice up a presentation
oh god god i remember like first
discovering transitions on powerpoint
and you just used that for
every [ __ ] slide you thought you were
the [ __ ] every single letter had a
transition
there was that one kid who would just do
like okay
bear in mind this transition is like 30
seconds long
just watching each single level bouncing
into the screen
star shake in the middle and the last
little moment would take [ __ ] forever
to like lock in
i remember that one man i remember this
one time
in my it class we had to create a
website right yeah so we could choose
a website on whatever topic we uh wanted
to create
so squarespace i know this would be
perfect for squarespace but um yeah i
chose to
make a website on the original nintendo
ds right
okay i'm specific yeah no no i don't
know why because i just i
was a nintendo kid back then and i
remember like i i was like doing a
really good job my teacher was like
at the time really impressed at the
website i had created because i was
actually putting effort in and like
unlike the other kids who were just like
[ __ ] around like you do in it yeah of
course
and then he was asking me oh so so what
are you going to name it and i was just
10 year old me i was like nine or 10
years trying to think of the coolest
name possible
i was like how about ds dominator no no
i got a better one how about ds
dominatrix
because i was like dominator dominant
like
dominatrix for a nine-year-old who
doesn't know what it means
sounds like a cool [ __ ] word it's
like dominator and the matrix
yeah that's that's like exactly my
mindset
and i just remember the teacher's face
being like
um that's great but uh probably
shouldn't call it that and i was like
why it's such a cool word dominatrix
i'm gonna call it dominatrix and he he
refused to let me call it dominatrix now
and
nine-year-old me was so [ __ ] pissed
because i thought of a [ __ ] brilliant
name
i don't understand me have you seen the
matrix